il fait pas le flanc barre jean luc
mélenchon à le faire croire qu'il ya du
monde et que non il avait déjà pas fait
il ya une quinzaine de jours quand il
avait considéré que ces macro kahn et
marquer le point et de ce pont du las il
a raison quand on voit la mobilisation
d'aujourd'hui qui est moitié moindre que
celle de la fin que la dernière qui est
elle même étaient déjà un échec les on
voit bien que les syndicats
effectivement sont groggy ils sont pas
forcément définitivement ko mais ils
sont groggy
ils sont groggy pourquoi parce qu'ils
sont divisés donc il ya la division
syndicale qui a pesé mais surtout ce qui
est important c'est ce qu'a dit
mélenchon là dans la fin de sa phrase
c'est son c'est le la bataille de
leadership sur le fond social entre les
syndicats et la france est soumise et
qui n'a pas réussi à créer ce ce pont et
à rompre le voilà ce qu'ont ceux qu'on
connaît maintenant dans paysage syndical
depuis des décennies d'indépendance par
rapport aux partis politiques voilà même
les liens entre la cgt et parti
communiste ne sont plus ce qu'ils
étaient et et contreur c'est peut-être
sans doute parce que la cgt avait trop
de liens avec le parti communiste qui
n'ont pas vu le soutien mélenchon
peut-être les relations grommelle un
jour le maillot émission pour mélenchon
ce concert le discours parce que dit
mélenchon par rapport à la tradition
syndicale française est un scandale
absolu c'est le syndicalisme français
s'est construit sur la séparation et
l'indépendance des critiques nées à tel
point que même quand tu as si j'étais en
vtt en vérité un briquet avec le parti
communiste andré semblant être
indépendante elle prétend mais que non
et donc quand il dit ça qui a l'air
banal c'est tout sauf banal ça ils
s'assoient sur plus d'un siècle de
tradition syndicale française c'est tout
c'est tout sauf banal et c'est très très
faux puisque sans remettre en cause
même s'ils ont du désir pour la
controverse que dit olivier le problème
les syndicats en france notamment par
rapport à la perception des syndicats en
allemagne avec un décalage de perception
qui est très important c'est que les
français assimile les syndicats aux jeux
politiques et leurs grilles de lecture
de l'action syndicale est vraiment une
transposition des grilles de lecture de
la compétition politique dans
précisément ils ne veulent plus donc le
l'association du syndicat avec l'action
politique était de mon point de vue une
clé d'échec une clé des chèques presse
ça se produit quand même cette
démobilisation dans un moment un peu
curieux parce que se trouve que l'image
des syndicats s'est plutôt améliorée
depuis
depuis deux ans elle s'est améliorée au
moment des manifestations contre la loi
travail qui ont été plutôt un succès non
couronnée par quoi il aura pas de
résultats oui c'était la fin de ma
phrase non couronnée par la satisfaction
de leurs exigences mais succès
mobilisation est là on a des objets de
mobilisation qui est très semblable est
pas du tout la même là le même succès de
d'entraînement parce que on n'est pas
dans le même moment politique parce qu
on est en début de quinquennat pas en
fin de quinquennat et surtout parce que
emmanuel macron fait ce pour quoi il a
été élu par ses électeurs
quand françois hollande donné le
sentiment en fin de course de faire
exactement contre-pied de ce pourquoi on
les choisit elle